(exploding)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is "believe,"
and I believe that you have
the ability to do something special
and I'm trying to help have a small impact
on your growth with these videos.
And so to help you on your journey,
today we're continuing
the Best of Tony series,
where we look at some of the best clips
that Tony Robinson's come up with.
Today's theme is "believe,"
and I hope you enjoy.
- Think about it, what's the Holy Grail
between somebody taking action or not?
It's one word: certainty.
When somebody is absolutely certain they,
the common word is "believe," right?
But you know, you can
believe at a general level
or you can believe with certainty.
When you're absolutely
certain that if I do this,
it's going to get that
result, and that result's
going to change my life, you'll do it.
When you think, "It absolutely
is not going to work,"
you're never going to do it.
The middle no man's land
of "Maybe it'll work,
maybe it won't," that's the
piece that kills people.
So if it's a must for you,
you got to make it work.
In our case, right, it's an example.
If it's not a must for
you and you're not sure,
you don't know what to do.
So years ago I'd look around and say,
"Okay, how do people get themselves
to follow through that haven't
been following through?
What's the difference?"
And I started interviewing
hundreds of people, literally.
And eventually thousands,
'cause I had thousands at my events,
so I'd ask the group to
give me their feedback.
And I came up with this model.
It's like the Holy Grail of belief.
Or the Holy Grail of momentum.
It's like the difference between
what makes the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer, right?
And the difference, we
all know, is mindset,
but like, how's that built?
So this is what I did.
I created these stupid
little, four little boxes.
And I'll scribble it here for you.
You think about the first thing
that determines whether you
can do something or not.
And I put that in this first box
at the top here on the left side.
It's potential.
Like what's the potential
of a human being?
Like when you guys started, you proved
something no one had done in history.
You ran the four-minute mile, right?
For golly-knows how many centuries,
they're trying to run a four-minute mile.
Roger Bannister does it, how did he do it?
Do you remember?
You did it in this industry, right?
You made a million bucks in a day.
No one had ever done
that in history, right?
After you did it a bunch
of other guys are doing it,
because it became possible.
Roger Bannister didn't just
go physically practice.
He made a shift in his head.
He practiced in his head,
'cause he could never
achieve it physically,
so he had to change in his head first
so the result became certain enough,
he believed it, and then
his body got him through.
After Roger Bannister ran
that four-minute mile,
within two years, 37 people
ran a four-minute mile.
- Wow.
- That's amazing.
- When no one in history had ever done.
Now here's how it works.
The potential for anybody getting
your product is extraordinary.
They could do what you've
done, as much more or less.
They can do whatever they want to do.
The potential's there,
the market's proven that.
Whether or not they
tap into that potential
has a lot to do with
what action they take,
which is the question
that came to me, right?
They got all this potential
but they're not taking action.
And we all know that the action they take
is going to determine
the results they get.
That's pretty obvious.
So most people have a belief
about what their real potential is,
no matter what you tell them.
And that affects how
much action they take.
And of course, that affects the result.
And then, ironically, that
result reinforces their belief.
And then that belief affects it.
So I'll give you an example.
Let's say a person has unlimited
potential, we all agree.
But they take little
action, little results, why?
'Cause they have to start with
a problem with their belief.
They don't believe it's
really going to happen for me.
"Maybe for Frank Kern,
'cause he's got the cool hair and stuff,
or maybe it's for you,
because you're so driven.
But it's not me.
Maybe Tony Robbins,
'cause he's he's a freak,
got these big teeth,"
whatever their thought process
(laughter)
is, they got this thing, right?
But what happens is, if you believe
that there's very little potential,
how much action you going to take?
- Nothing.
- Nothing, little.
And when you take little
potential with little action,
what kind of results do you get?
Lousy little results.
And when you get little results,
what does that do to your belief?
You go, "See, I told you
this was a waste of time.
Told you this wouldn't work."
And then what happens, you
tap even less potential,
you take even less action,
you get even worse results,
and your belief gets even weaker.
And this sucker feeds on itself
until you are in a downward spiral
- [Frank] It's poisonous.
- It's poisonous and it's self-fulfilling.
Now, what if something could happen
that could come along and fill you
with a sense of absolute certainty?
Not like, "I believe," but where you know.
In you guys' case, mine as
well, we knew 'cause we had to.
'Cause we burned the boats,
there was no other option.
We had to find a way.
We weren't going to live that way.
We all did it in different
ways and for different reasons,
but in essence, that was it.
If you get yourself in
a state of certainty
that this is going to work,
I'm going to find a way,
and if this doesn't work,
I will make the way,
then you tap a lot more potential.
And when you're certain in your potential
you take massive action.
And when you take massive action,
you really believe in something,
you get great results.
When you get great results,
your brain goes, "See,
I told you I was a stud.
I told you this thing would work out."
Now you're even stronger.
You tap more potential,
take greater action,
get greater results.
That's how you went
from 300 bucks in a week
to 2500 in five days,
to 100,000 in a month,
to a million bucks in a day.
Same thing with you.
And we get momentum.
It's why the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer.
Now some people go out and they go,
"Well, I'm going to take a
bunch of action, alright?
I'm going to open this
product, I'm going to try it,"
and they'll say to you, "I even did it."
But it's like a salesman who
goes and knocks on the door
and he knocks on 100 doors and says,
- You don't want one of these, do you?
- Yeah, exactly right.
(laughter)
And even if he doesn't say it verbally,
his face says it because he
doesn't believe it's going to work,
so his voice, his body,
the execution, is so weak.
If he talks to 100 people,
somebody's going to buy out of pity.
They don't want his kids to starve, right?
But he's not going to get the result.
So the core difference in people is,
how do you produce certainty
when the world isn't giving it to you?
You go out and you try
and you try, in your case,
you're 100,000 in debt
and nothing's working.
How do you keep yourself going?
The way you did it, the way I did it,
the way you're doing it,
we may not have done it consciously,
is, we didn't change our
potential, that was there.
And it wasn't even taking more action.
Taking more action with a belief
that's not going to work's
not going to change anything.
We got results in our head
that made us feel certain,
as if it had already happened.
True or false for you?
- True.
- Right, so give me an example.
So people know I'm not
just making this crap up.
- Well, I mean, just
like when I had nothing,
I already knew I was driving like Ferraris
and Porsches and stuff 'cause
I always wanted those cars.
I already knew I was going to have them.
It was inevitable.
- [Tony] Right.
- [Frank] That was just
my inevitable outcome.
- But how did you do that?
Did you have a ritual, did
you think about it regularly?
Was it one time you thought about it
or was it something you
had an obsession towards?
- I had an obsession towards it.
I used to work at a video store,
which is the last "job"
I ever had in my life.
- Thank god.
- And I used to go to
work almost every day,
and I used to bring two magazines
with me to read on my breaks.
Entrepreneur Magazine, just to read
about business and everything else,
to read about what other people are doing,
look for role models.
And I used to carry an Autotrader with me.
And I used to look at
Porsches that were for sale.
And people always used to ask me,
"What are you doing with
that Autotrader magazine?"
I'm like, "Well, I'm just
picking out the Porsche
that I'm going to buy when I'm--"
- Right, which probably
got you a lot of crap.
- It did.
People made fun of me.
I actually had a boss at that job tell me,
"You know, you really shouldn't
do that to yourself, John.
Because it's very, very likely
that that is never going to happen.
It's very likely that you're
never going to have that car."
that's the kind of belief he
was trying to put in my head.
And I was like, "No, you don't realize
that it's inevitable
that I will drive here
sometime in the near future with that car,
when I'm not working for you,
and drop movies off for you
to put back on the shelf."
- And anybody wants to succeed
has got to know, it doesn't just happen.
You can buy a product, but you also,
with that product, have
got to condition yourself.
You got to make it a must
and you got to get a ritual.
And if you do it, whatever
you used to dream about
that you thought was so
huge, you'll just live it.
You'll live it like you
lived this yesterday,
like we're living the
life that we envisioned.
'Cause we had to, and 'cause we played
this game with our head.
We got the belief to be real
by seeing it enough times
and feeling it enough times
'til our brain believed it
and then it made it happen.
- Which raised the potential,
which made us take more action,
which got us better results,
which raised our beliefs again.
- That's right.
And then that's why the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer.
So instead of bitching
about it, change it.
This process is the Holy Grail.
It's where the whole game changes.
And anybody can do it, and they
can do it in a few minutes,
and if they do it a few minutes each day,
then they get a different life.
They do it a few minutes one time,
their life changes for the day.
We're defined by our rituals.
Everybody's got rituals, certain
things they do every day.
And what we three have in common
and anybody that I know of who has a life
that they're living
that was once a vision,
is we saw it again and again and again,
even when it didn't work,
even when you lost 100 grand,
even when I'm working as a janitor.
There was something we
would not give up on.
And if somebody watching
wants to change their life,
they got to decide what
they won't give up on
and then put themselves in this state
of momentum by a couple little rituals.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what you
think of Tony's message.
It's one that I, obviously, agree with
in that it's "believe,"
but I'd love to hear what
you guys have to say.
What did you learn from this video?
Please let me know, leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm looking forward to
hearing what you have to say.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love, see you soon.
(exploding)